You know Faker as the greatest player to ever play League of Legends.
But in 2015, the most exciting mid laner in the scene was spending a lot of his time playing
from behind a substitute.
In interviews, Faker said he was willing to do whatever was best for the team.
But actions speak louder than words.
As 2015 began Faker is coming off a season that saw him try and fail to carry SKT to Worlds.
But if anything that season showed how incredible a player Faker really is
even when the situation around him is unstable.
Near the end of that year Riot released Azir. While the champion was released in September he
wasn't enabled for Worlds. But Azir's intricate design made fans wonder
how exactly Faker would take advantage of it. Between two of his accounts
Faker played 42 games on Azir in 2014 and while his win rate wasn't all that
high he did make some highlights.
The rules for the 2015 LCK season got rid of sister teams.
So Faker and Bengi joined MaRin, Wolf and Bang from T1 S.
But the mid laner from S, Easyhoon, also made the switch.
And as the meta started to shift from assassins to control mages,
it became clear that Faker was gonna have to share time
even at the beginning of the split.
"Wait, wait what's this? What's this I spy in the SKT booth, it's not Faker."
"It's Easyhoon. Faker, here's how we operate. We pick our star player into an unfavorable match and we kick
him out when he doesn't do well."
In the LCK, Faker spent most of his time playing champions like Ezreal, Ahri and LeBlanc.
Meanwhily Easyhoon was playing champions like Lulu, Xerath and Cassiopeia.
But outside of the LCK, Faker racked up games on Azir in solo queue.
He played 130 games on the champion in 2015. More than any other champion he played.
For someone who's substitute was supposed to be handling control mages
Faker was spending a lot of his time trying to master one.
But in week six of the season. Faker finally got a chance to show off his Azir.
"We may finally get to see Faker's Azir. This would be very exciting."
"We've seen a lot of clips of him from solo queue."
"It's happening."
It wasn't exactly the debut fans were expecting.
(Casting)
As both mid laners continue to share time, SKT finished second in the regular season.
Faker played 20 games and Easyhoon played 12.
In the playoffs, Faker was a key part of SKT’s reverse sweep against CJ Entus.
After Easyhoon played in the Game 1 loss, Faker stepped in.
But when it came time for the grand finals against the GE Tigers,
Faker sat out the entire series with Easyhoon, playing mid with Cassiopeia and Azir, to sweep their opponents.
(Casting)
Faker took the opportunity in a post-game interview to say he was happy that his team won,
but he was willing to do whatever it took to make sure he could play in key series in the future.
As SKT prepared for MSI. The question of their mid-lane still remained.
But with days to go before the tournament, Faker was still practicing Azir in solo queue.
At MSI, Faker got another chance to pull out the Azir. But maybe in the least risky way possible.
Against tournament underdogs, Beşiktaş e-Sports Club.
Still it was his birthday and fans ate it up.
(Casting)
Faker got to play Azir two more times that tournament.
But by the time Grand Finals rolled around, he was riding the bench for the first three games against EDG.
However, they put Faker back in with Kassadin for Game 4, forced a Game 5, and eventually his undefeated
LeBlanc was countered in the final game of the series.
(Casting)
Returning to LCK for the summer, the narrative about Faker was still the same, he was an incredible talent.
But there were things Easyhoon could do that Faker just couldn't.
(Casting)
Faker was playing more games but Easyhoon was still considered the better Azir player.
Even though Faker was grinding out games in solo queue.
Faker didn't get another chance to show how his Azir had progressed until week seven.
Playing a 0-9 SBENU Sonicboom. Faker played Azir into Vel'Koz,
and he picked up his first LCK win on Azir.
But, just barely.
(Casting)
Strangely this seems to have been the turning point for Faker's Azir.
He played Azir two more times that season. Going up against the KOO Tigers and CJ Entus.
Winning both times. As SKT entered the playoffs in first place they only had to beat KT Rolster.
This time Easyhoon rode the bench as Faker played all three games
playing Riven, Diana… and Azir.
(Casting)
SKT brought Easyhoon to Worlds but Faker still played the lion's share of the games the tournament
The Juggernaut patch that hit before Worlds though
changed a lot of the pick ban priority and Faker played a lot more
Ryze than he did Azir. And in their grand final series against the KOO Tigers. It was Faker, not Easyhoon,
who was in for every single game.
Easyhoon left for China after 2015, and noted that while he was willing to share time and make sacrifices for SKT
the shadow of the Unkillable Demon King was a lot colder than he expected.
And as it turned out, Faker picked a pretty good time to get good at Azir.
In 2016 he became known for his unbelievable plays on the champion.
(Casting)
Even though 2015's control mage meta was perfect for Easyhoon.
Faker had surpassed him. Even the greats in League of Legends have bad metas or picks they struggle with.
But Faker set out to prove that those limits don't apply to him.
And he did.